Lisa G has a theory that Ronnie died his
goatee last night I think so yes it was
really white yeah I noticed that too and
even the guys from TV put up a thing
while Ronnie was in vehicle look how
white Ronnie's beard is a blissing a
billy goat but I didn't see him I didn't
notice it did he dye it last night do
you think looks like it okay Ron come on
in we want to see the dye job you did on
your goatee oh yeah you died I'm not
saying nothing I'm just saying you dyed
it cuz I saw it yesterday and was white
is like Santa Claus yeah so what did you
do cuz yes think was like white did you
realize how wide it was like what made
you go home yesterday a diet why you
gonna beat up JD cuz you does he runs
with every little thing to Jason or Gary
or something on the TV you know who did
today
[ __ ] okay Lisa did JD say anything to
you about it no why are you blaming JD
cuz he does it with everything man he
didn't do it this - I don't care he
could tell me from now until next year
you don't believe it no I wouldn't even
send an email on the wrap-up show
yesterday Ronnie always is threatening
to beat up JD I ain't ready to beat him
up you were like what do you live for
not because everything is it you know
you're talking on you know John invites
you in right so I go in and I'm talking
about some so I might not know
everything okay know this once then he
laughs at everything everything's funny
where he started laughing and then I
laugh and everybody was glued glued to
the radio why is that funny
you're laughing president first right I
love
I had nothing to do with them okay right
yeah okay what'd you put in there minced
men yeah would you calm it through yeah
they get these little brush thing that's
a little more elaborate than just a comb
through because let notice if this'll
look bad there's like a pattern brush
thing right but you're like going in a
specific way no no you take it's got
this little brush right a little small
brush can you just go through it but
you're not putting it in the hair in
your head or you know no I got great
hair back in my butt and your beard
you're doing it but I think he did a
decent job because you left a little bit
of gray yeah I try to leave it natural
looking and I got to tell you in some
spots it's super dark sometimes the dot
yes sometimes the dye gets real you know
it's a nice thing like see this one part
I don't you can see it I know what you
mean under the lip pointer it spilled on
his chin yeah well maybe I just spilled
something I don't know how longs it take
you to do that five minutes okay and you
did it this morning cuz you get up early
he gets up way early what time you get
up 3:15 I guess I carried a dog
so like at 3:15 you're dying your beer
now it was about a quarter to 4:00 yeah
because he takes care of the dog minutes
I would do it at night I think you I
forgot last night yeah how often you
have to dye your beard once a week
well yeah you get roots
did you forget for a while or did you no
I'm telling you it's a weekend to paint
in the ansel there's annoying